well that was stressful wasn't it you're
watching the press preview first look at
what is on the front pages then as they
arrive coming up
uh we see what's making the headlines
papers in very late it has to be said
with the daily mails consultant editor
andrew pearce and the writer
and broadcaster may hear bose welcome to
both of you
one and so far told you that late uh one
at least on the uh on the football or
the ft rather the uh
metro is coming up later the ft leads
with the british finance technology
company wise
and their landmark nine billion pound
direct listing see i told you they were
late
uh anyway uh mihir bose and andrew
pearce are here
me here they've broken their semi-final
glass ceiling
it's taken 55 years but thank goodness
it went the right way
indeed it's a fantastic match uh i mean
you know a lot of people felt
england had beaten ukraine so simply so
easily this would be an easy match it
was actually a very tough match
and uh a match where england went behind
and then this they
won through a penalty that harry kane
who normally never misses a penalty
missed and scored but this is a fabulous
night because in years to come
people will talk about where were you
when england finally got to a final
of a major international competition the
second one after the world cup
and you know i'll have to say i was
talking to anna botting you know
and with andrew pierce because i had to
take my eye
off the football to be sure that i
didn't miss this but i think people will
talk about that
and this is actually you know the
monkeys off the back
football is is the national game bigger
than any other game
england have have produced sites that
have always disappointed and this side
gives the impression under gareth
southgate's leadership and a very very
um influential manager very far-sighted
manager
that england could finally break through
and be considered
a major footballing power which they
haven't been for a long time
they've made many false promises but
really this time i feel that dawn is
coming italy will not be easy
but i feel you know the dawn is about to
break
i mean look at the fans there i don't if
you can see them yet andrew but uh
leaving wembley boris johnson has to be
said took quite a lot
of stick even from the like likes of the
german chancellor
for the number of fans that he'd let
into wembley for this occasion
um but what a night they'll have to uh
to go home and remember apart from the
8 000 or so uh danes who were there
look it's historic i i was on a tube
earlier this evening
going north and this smell of alcohol in
my carriage it nearly
i was nearly drunk just breathing in the
fumes but the mood the atmosphere
was incredibly buoyant and cheerful and
i didn't know it was possible anna to be
quite so emotional about a football
match do you know what i know about
football i could write in the back
of a shrunken postage stamp and i found
it almost
unbearable to watch tonight because of
the tension and when kane didn't put
that penalty
in the net but then got it on the
rebound i i thought it was gonna faint
it was absolutely fantastic well done
the team
you just can see particularly if they
win this uh tournament
it's gonna be arrived cigarette
southgate
yeah i mean well well exactly yes he's
he's given a level of calm hasn't he
a man who knows all too well what it's
like to go out of one of these
tournaments
me here you know he's put he's put he's
put a number of things to bed hasn't he
with the
the performance tonight and throughout
this competition
absolutely and and what he's done he's
guided the team very well
you know he basically said this is the
second semi-final
england have been for successive
competitions uh
the russian uh world cup and now here
and he said no that is not the limit of
our ambition
we've got an everest to climb and all
and also throughout this tournament
he's taken controversial decisions you
know there was a
early on when england struggled in the
group stages there was a hell of a
a movement to say harry kane should be
sacked you know he shouldn't be
played would play some other player play
grealish and so on you know and in
football in sport
we all become instant selectives and you
know we all have opinion saying
we know better than anybody else but you
know gareth southgate has maintained his
composure
and he has kept his head which is not
very easy given the noise around him
absolutely uh first papers in the metro
wins the competition
uh we knew they'd always be late they're
a picture of uh harry kane and phil
foden another of his decisions lots of
people thought he should be on there
on the pitch a bit more finally there
and that is the point isn't it
that we just don't get into finals 55
years 1966 we all know the history of
that
we've been singing the songs for as long
as we can remember andrew
finally literally we're in a final
yeah it's fantastic i mean i i was born
in 1961 but i'm afraid i don't remember
the the world cup final in 1966 i don't
even know if you had a television to
watch it on to be honest
um but but but it's it's it's a bit like
1066 the battle of hastings everybody
knows the date that england won the
world cup because it's the only time
you've won a football tournament
an international football tournament we
all know it was 1966 it was 4-2
and jeff first one got a hat-trick i
think jeff hurst was somewhere
very close to um uh gareth southgate
tonight
mihir will know more about this than me
but they wheeled him out as like a lucky
mascot well
let's wheel him out again on a sunday
night against italy
and i think now they've beaten denmark i
think they're going to win
because from what i read about the match
last night
uh italy were lucky to win yeah many
people thought it should have been spain
go and be here
final 30 seconds to you
but i i think italy will be will be a
difficult proposition italy is a good
team
but i think with the faith england have
shown with the ability they've shown and
the belief they've shown
i think england will win and i hope
england
because before the tournament began i
put my money in england so i i
i knew so i want william he'll be out
yeah well what else did you get what
else did you get
i got odds of six to one which which i
thought were very
well we can talk a lot more about that
can't you because we're seeing you at
the eleven we've got loads to talk about
more fans reaction no doubt
more of those pictures the bars are
emptying wembley is emptying
uh but everyone has to do it all again
obviously on sunday